möglicherweise auch in Peking und das
ist noch mal das Stichwort von ihnen
erfahrt das mit ihnen noch mal kurz
aufnehmen möchte wir sind in diesen
Tagen konfrontiert mit Bildern von ganz
oben vom Himmel über den USA wo
plötzlich ein offenbar chinesischer
spionageballon auftauchte und dann nach
einigen Tagen hier sehen wir den noch
mal abgeschossen wird vom US-Militär es
bleiben aber doch ziemlich viele Fragen
nach diesem Bilder nach diesen knappen
Bildern die uns erreicht haben hier Herr
Hanning wenn wir hören dass dieser
Ballon dann irgendwann abgeschossen
wurde und aber vorher ja erheblich lange
mehrere Tage offenbar über
amerikanisches Gebiet geflogen ist ist
das jetzt ein Zeichen von Stärke dass
man den abschießt oder ein Zeichen von
Schwäche dass der überhaupt dahin kommen
konnte und solange über Amerika fliegen
konnte naja also der Einsatz von Balance
so Aufklärung hat ja eine lange
Tradition das muss man glaube ich
hinzufügen so ganz neu ist das ja gibt
es nicht was wir da erleben dass der
abgeschlossen wird um sich mal die
Apparate anzuschauen die da mit dem
Ballon zusammen als Aufklärungsmittel
offen und nicht dienten das kann ich
nachvollziehen aber hätte man den da
nicht einsammeln müssen oben hättest ja
keine anderen Möglichkeiten
Techniker aber denen so einzufangen ist
wahrscheinlich so ganz einfach erfahrt
wer das möglich gewesen militärisch den
anderen zu holen ja ich würde eher sagen
nein also
gut man es gab diese Fälle schon vorher
es ist nicht das erste Mal und das hat
man anders gelöst als durch abschießen
das stimmt
aber gleichwohl natürlich man die
chinesische Behauptung das sei so eine
Wetterbeobachtung die halte ich in der
Tat für sehr mutig dann hätte man ja
auch die andere hätte man ja die
Amerikaner auch vorher unterrichten
müssen dass ihr Hoheit verlässt wird
mehrere Tage über Amerika und fällt
offenbar ja nicht auf erste Mal ich kann
Zeichen auch nicht so ganz einfach die
zu detektieren nicht denn sie können
natürlich über Radarsystem erstmal
metalldetektieren aber das ist ja nun
ein sehr kleiner Teil oder ein sehr
schwierig zu detektieren so stelle ich
mir das jedenfalls vor und als sogar
Montan aber hat man sie auch entdeckt ja
danach mehrere Tagen dann bleibt aber
auch weiter in die Frage wenn der Befehl
vom US-Präsidenten am Mittwoch gegeben
wird so schnell wie möglich diesen
Ballon darunter zu holen und es passiert
am Samstag was sagt das dann über die
Führung naja also man musste ja den so
abschießen ah das keine Schäden
entstanden am Erdboden und B dass man
natürlich auch die Apparate sagen konnte
und deswegen hat man gewartet bis das
Meer erreicht wurde war eigentlich ein
sehr sinnvolles Vorgehen aus meiner
Sicht das hat man überlegt sie nicken ja
Fahrt bleiben bei Ihnen nicht auch viele
Fragezeichen bei diesen Bildern bei
dieser Geschichte was ging ihnen durch
den Kopf mir ging durch den Kopf das ist
natürlich auch eine politische Message
mal abgesehen von der militärischen
Notwendigkeit den vom Himmel zu holen
das ist natürlich auch ein Zeichen dass
man
durchaus Konflikt bereit ist mir Blick
auf China das zeigt natürlich diese
große Auseinandersetzung der wir auch
sind zwischen USA und Peking die ja den
Makrokosmos beherrscht wir gucken nur
auf die Ukraine wir schauen nur auf
Russland im Prinzip geht das ja um die
Frage abschießt ja es ist eine es hat
eine Signalwirkung ich meine man kann
das auch anders klären man kann ja auch
anrufen sagen hör mal ja ihr habt euch
verflogen oder wie auch immer recht also
man muss nicht unbedingt abschießen weil
ich und das ist eine das ist schon eine
politische Aussage sag ich mal die Frage
ist nur ob wir in Zukunft in einer
multipolarer werdenden Welt wo wir
Nächte wie Indien haben
USA China Japan auch starke Mittelmächte
ob das die richtige Gangart ist in der
Zukunft ja da habe ich eine Frage zwar
nachgefragt erfahrt sie sagen jetzt das
war sozusagen eine Machtdemonstration
ein Luftballon abzuschießen mittwochs
kommt der Befehl von Präsidenten
samstags wird er dann auch schon
ausgeführt er als der Ballon endlich
über mehr ist die ganzen Tage aber noch
Informationen gesammelt hat da hat man
den mit dem Kampfjet oben abgeschossen
und das ist jetzt eine
Machtdemonstration also macht er so ist
vielleicht zu viel aber politische
Signal auf jeden Fall nicht aber man
kann es natürlich auch anders sehen das
hat verdammt lange gedauert und die
konnte dieser Ballon da überhaupt
reinkommen wir hatten ja mal den Fall
von diesen Piloten der auf dem Roten
Platz gelandet ist da hatte man sich
auch viele Fragen gestellt im Kalten
Krieg wie kommt der dadurch ne die
Fragen wird man sich auch stellen müssen
so ein bisschen erinnert o2 fallen und
powers wir erinnern uns der ja auch
abgeschlossen worden ist über Russland
mit ähnlicher Mission gehabt
ganz ein bisschen hinter die Kulissen
blicken wie gesagt
verteidigungspolitisch Sprecher wie wird
hier in Deutschland über diesen Fall
gesprochen möglicherweise ist ja davon
auszugehen dass auch bei uns schon
Ballon rüber geflogen ist und wir den
eben nicht bemerkt haben naja machen wir
uns nichts vor es gibt Spionage über
Satelliten aber eben auch über
Luftballons und dieser Ballon war schon
eine Provokation wenn beiden mittwochs
sagt Befehl zum Abschluss und Samstag
kommt dass das sind immer noch drei Tage
wo China erklären können und die
eskalieren können sie haben bewusst
provoziert das ist meine Ansicht und
über Südamerika gibt es auch eine
Leuchten Ballon gehen Sie davon aus dass
bei uns die Dinge auch schon überflogen
sind ich kann das nicht ausschließen
zwei Dinge erstens es gibt auch ein
Wettbewerb zwischen Autokratien und
Demokratien und das müssen wir
betrachten bei Putin wie auch bei
Präsident erschien und darum müssen wir
auch für Werte für Moral und für Stärke
der Demokratien werden und zweitens
müssen wir uns auch sicherheitspolitisch
darauf einstellen das heißt die
Sicherheitsarchitektur Deutschland was
machen sie wenn sie nächste Woche den
Ballon hier über Kaiser die Windrichtung
stimmt auch nicht das wird die auch noch
hinzugeben
also die konnten den Ballon aus China
nur deswegen starten okay Stratosphäre
eine entsprechende Winter okay jetzt
nehmen wir das Ding fliegt über
Frankfurt
also wir müssen unsere langfristig auf
solche Eskalation ausrichten können
nicht dass wir sie wollen aber wir
müssen vorbereitet sein ich will damit
sagen auch das russische vorgehen wenn
es jetzt nicht nur militärisches in der
Ukraine ist ein Dauerläufer es ist ein
Wettbewerb und wird von China und
Nordkorea unterstützt und darauf müssen
wir uns Europa einstellen wir müssen
natürlich auch green Deal machen aber
wir müssen viel mehr Sicherheit das ist
die große Frage die ist auch ganz
wichtig wie wir wo wir in dieser Welt
stehen was wir mit den großen Konflikten
machen und der große Konflikt kam ja im
Kleinen in Form dieses Nina 99
Luftballons plötzlich über Montaner wenn
das über Köln über Frankfurt über Berlin
passiert was machen Sie mit dem Ballon
das ist eine ganz praktische Frage
schießen Sie den ab und dann muss
entweder Verteidigung oder Kanzler
müssen entscheiden und da sind wir nicht
vorbereitet deswegen fordern wir ja von
neuen Johnen zum Beispiel ein Nationalen
Sicherheitsrat in einer solchen Krise
muss man schnell zusammenkommen abwägen
da müssen die Ministerien zusammenstehen
wie würde das das Militär machen müssen
sie erstmal gucken haben sie überhaupt
die Mitte müssen doch erstmal bei uns
fehlen noch die Basics wir haben doch im
Moment eine nicht einsatzbereit
klar
aber ich meine Balance sind doch kein
Thema für unsere Sicherheit nicht und
und neue Gremien wie Nationalen
Sicherheitsrat auch nicht wir brauchen
eine erstmal eine einsatzbereite Armee
mit mehr kampfmanns also jetzt hat und
die 100 Milliarden reichen nicht aus
dafür da braucht ein bisschen mehr
investieren und wie die Bundeswehr
brauchen mehr Personal sie muss
attraktiver werden sie muss wie Pistole
richtig sagt in der Mitte der
Gesellschaft sind oder ohne werfe ich
aber da steht sie nicht
Ballon würde ich sagen
ganz einfache Frage mit oder ich glaube
schon dass wir darüber nachdenken müssen
die Wehrpflicht wieder einzuführen wie
wollen wir das denn machen die Landes
und bündnisverteilung wir brauchen noch
Manpower die Bundeswehr mit 180.000 Mann
und dem Material was er da auf dem Hof
haben nicht da vieles nicht
einsatzbereit das reicht doch nicht ne
das ist eine Mammutaufgabe das kriegen
wir auch nicht nächstes Jahr über
nächstes Jahr aber die Basics fehlen
doch wir brauchen ja auch eine sehr
Motivation bei Umfragen unter 20% der
Deutschen sind überhaupt bereit mit der
Waffenhand für Deutschland zu kämpfen
bei einer Partei die vor allen Dingen
mit der Kriegs Rhetorik in Ukraine
richtig Meditation unterwegs ist da ist
es wahrscheinlich gar keiner zu wenig
ja ich glaube wir haben ein Problem in
Deutschland mit dem patientismus wir
verstecken ja auch die Bundeswehr im
Grunde war Nationalfeiertagen schauen
nicht machen wie die Franzosen ihr
Nationalfeiertag gegeben und bei uns hat
man eher den Eindruck einer Begriff
Veranstaltung ich sag das mal so hart ja
also das muss man einfach sehen das
gehört mit zum Gesamtbild also ich
glaube schon dass wir uns umstellen
müssen wir brauchen mehr Patriotismus
glaube ich in der Tat wahrscheinlich
Wehrpflicht im klassischen Sinne sehe
ich eigentlich eher als unrealistisch an
aber eine allgemeine Dienstpflicht auch
aus integrationspolitischen Ansicht also
ins äh Israel zum Beispiel ist natürlich
ganz wichtig für die Integration wir
sind bei der veröffentlich gewesen
deswegen am Ende dieser Sendung noch mal
ganz schnell zu einem Orte zurück sie
haben gedient sie saßen auf dem Leopard
sie sind mittlerweile im Bundestag das
heißt sie sind davon etwas weiter
entfernt und doch wenn wir über diese
Themen in diesen Zeiten reden könnten
Sie sich vorstellen noch einmal dorthin
zurückzukehren können Sie vorstellen
Leopard noch zu fahren
jeder muss das machen was er kann und da
gibt es gut ausgebildete Soldaten und
sie stellen mir die Frage der ich immer
gesagt habe wir brauchen mindestens zwei
Prozent für die Bundeswehr und wir
müssen uns modernisieren und viel
stärker aufstellen und wir haben als CDU
ja auf dem Bundesparteitag beschlossen
eine verpflichtende Gesellschaft ja weil
ich glaube dass das nämlich nur sagen
wir brauchen nicht die Wehrpflicht nach
alte Muster aber wir brauchen dazu
fähige und bereite Bürgerinnen und
Bürger war es aber gerade was erfahrt
ihr auch angesprochen hat dass nur noch
ein winziger Bruchteil der Deutschen
überhaupt bereit wäre das Land das
eigene Land zu verteidigen sie gehören
dazu ich gehöre dazu und dafür müssen
wir auch werden dafür müssen wir
einstehen wir müssen vor allem als
Politik die Mittel zur Verfügung stellen
und da hat mal eben der Einzelplan 14
Absenkung erfahren wird für vier Jahre
eingefroren Herr Pistole ist
aufgefordert das Ding jetzt 16 drehen